that was me for nine years i was a
speechwriter for the epa during the day
and then stand up comic at night all
right so here we go so you started
moonlighting as a comedian at the ripe
old age of one 24 24 when do most
comedians start getting in front of
people one thing i believe very firmly
is that nobody's funny until 25.
that's a pretty good rule you can
you sometimes see people who are younger
than that and you can kind of tell
they're gonna be funny but when they're
older they're maybe not funny yet and
they're not funny yet because no life
experience interesting no perspective
their brains aren't developed exactly
yeah
i mean they're not good at anything
they're in their early 20s i mean for
all the young people listening to this
there's hope for you
did i just [ __ ] on half your audience
like your audience was like 19 and i'm
like their brains don't work
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward veteran stand up
comedian tv writer for john oliver until
recently he's got a new gig now
and the
blogger for the the political comedy
blog which is right up our alley i might
be wrong jeff mauer welcome jeff thanks
a lot for having me thank you so
freaking stand-up comedian for 18 years
out of dc uh but you were a speechwriter
by day for the epa which is very very
serious stuff
um so were you like batman where it was
like
was it
yeah
if uh
if batman peaks at being a you know
middling stand-up comic uh in b rooms
throughout the midwest yeah kind of like
that but yes that's the idea i always
had a change of clothes in my drawer at
work
and then had to change into my stand-up
comedy clothes and go do a gig at night
you needed to you had to change into
this uniform we see that exactly
the casual you don't want to be too good
looking you don't want to be too like
together you can't wear some people can
pull off a suit but generally you want
to be like casual on stage so i i gotta
say check it out if i went to a comedy
club and some dude showed up in a suit
from their very officious day job at the
epa or whatever i'd be like this dude's
not funny enough yeah you'd be like i
came here to relax
exactly yeah um so you went to
georgetown which produces a lot of
world-class comics right i mean like uh
i i think of when i think the first
among them but yeah it says the the
pantheon it starts with me the mountain
i'm not the only one it's jeff malware
uh yeah who else jim gaffigan
john mulaney and nick kroll john delaney
and nick kroll were there at the same
time they were they were there when i
was there mike barbiglia
oh wow that's a lot jacket for jackie
novak
yeah
for a second
[Laughter]
yeah and mike was kind of mike was a
little ahead of millennium crow so mike
started an improv troupe that melania
and kroll were in when i was there and i
would go to the improv shows and i'd be
like this is this is hilarious and it
kind of spoiled me for improv forever
because i thought like improv is great i
didn't realize yeah improv is great when
[ __ ] john mullaney and nick kroll are
in the improv troupe otherwise that's
usually not that's usually not the case
it's usually terrible yeah because those
guys are usually not in the troop
but uh yeah at the time i was like oh
man this is [ __ ] funny
wow so were you bitten by the comedy bug
at that point you went to grad school
afterwards so i guess yeah the bug
didn't get you that bad yet no yeah yeah
no well and also like well before that i
mean i was just you know we got comedy
central in my house in 1989 when i was
nine years old and i just you know
watched comedy central constantly
so like i love stand up because that's
all comedy central was back then was
stand up in mystery science theater
so i loved
stand-up and always wanted to do it but
like i'm not really i'm not a theater
kid i'm not an extrovert so it took me
24 years to get up there and actually
try it wow yeah that's so interesting
whoa
uh
so
after
georgetown you went to grad school for
politics and economics yeah right yeah
wow you're very learned
well thanks
thanks i'm glad i could wave my degrees
around that's what i came here to do
that's what people want from their
comedians too they want business suits
and advanced degrees
before we start
do you have a master's degree from an
accredited
institution because other than that you
are not qualified to make me laugh
exactly oh you're all but dissertation
go [ __ ] yourself we don't want to hear
from you then [ __ ] man you finished a
dissertation no i didn't no i didn't no
i didn't and that's why that's why i i'm
not very famous as a comedian i i i know
all the famous people we have a master's
degree
they've all got phd's every last one of
them yes often multiple phds how else
would you become a comedian
and then uh you
did the peace corps but it was
abbreviated because of security problems
all right yeah yeah it was so this was
morocco in 2004. we were the first
group back in
in morocco in 2004 and there is i mean
there's a very long story but it's just
there's a problem with the home stay
i was married at the time holy [ __ ] i'm
married now but to a different lady but
uh
yeah and it was like the home stay was
no good and they're like you they they
said like do you want to uh
like re-up or go back and like go go
back because there's no good so does
that mean you could say like hey i was
in the peace corps um and it was like i
mean because that's totally legit you
weren't the peace corps i wasn't the
peace corps i don't get the civil
service points for it that's cool
because i didn't uh finish so then you
came back and um became a speechwriter
for the epa is that right yes yeah i was
just so that was that was me for nine
years i was a speechwriter for the epa
during the day and then stand up comic
at night all right so here we go so you
started moonlighting as a comedian at
the ripe old age of 1 24 24 which is
um not old clearly
but
not young i suppose in comic con jesus
if that's not young i mean i'm 42 now
but no but 24 is not young
i mean it's young in absolute terms but
i was wondering when do most comedians
start getting in front of people one
thing i believe very firmly is that
nobody's funny until 25.
that's a pretty good rule you can
you sometimes see people who are younger
than that and you can kind of tell
they're going to be funny but then
they're older they're maybe not funny
yet and they're not funny yet because
no life experience interesting no
perspective their brains aren't
developed exactly yeah
i mean they're not good at anything
they're in their early 20s i mean for
all the young people listening to this
there's hope for you
you get to 25 and then you can just be
like hey am i [ __ ] funny now did i
just [ __ ] on half your audience like
your audience was like 19 and i'm like
their brains don't work
it's an objective fact their brain's not
done forming yet yeah so there's hope
hope hope for the the youngs um so
you're like hey i'm in i'm in front of
audi uh audiences right in the naked
time because i'm about to become funny
that's true i would end every set go
well all right that wasn't very good but
come back in a year so your colleagues
at the epa know your community tonight
obviously because you can't hide that
[ __ ] for like night correct yeah no no
way right the other comedians how many
of them had normal day jobs like you
where i was in dc all of them all of
them which i think made for a much
healthier scene i i think people don't
realize that like dc is a very good
stand-up scene a lot of second cities
you know dc boston denver seattle these
are really good stand-up cities and i
think one of the reasons the first
reason is obviously like the club to
comic ratio is pretty good whereas in
new york and la there are just a billion
comics and it's really hard to get stage
time you want to start in a second city
and then move
to a bigger city when you have a bit of
a name when you have a name you can
tread on everyone wants to book you
but before that and you're just trying
to prove that you're funny it's just
really it's really hard to get that
critical mass going and you can't get
good without stage time and then you
can't get stage time because you're not
any good so it's
really a lot better to start in
a medium-sized city so this is some very
very practical advice for my listeners
who want to get into comedy and there
are some for sure sure so jeff mauer
says look
cut your teeth in a city that has a
scene but is not necessarily like the
new york or la because you get more
stage time more reps
uh maybe
like people are are like less of
[ __ ] to you i don't know if that's
true but there are there are more
scammers in new york and la who will do
these shows that are like bring 20
people with you and they always promise
like yeah and the club owner is going to
be there and we're going to we're going
to you know spot talent like that
doesn't happen they just want you to
bring 20 people to their show so those
people exist in new york and la and also
the other thing that happens in second
city is very few people like trying to
make it there's so many like aggressive
hustlers in new york and l.a it can get
pretty
annoying there are people who are
in comedy and the only thing they're
good at is promoting their career
they're not good at comedy they're good
at promoting themselves so what does
that progression look like for a
fledgling comedian and then when's like
when's the benchmark where you're like
okay now i'm like
you know like what quote unquote like a
real comedian i'm because i didn't feel
like a real community you're exactly
right that there's like a dividing line
for me it's when i quit my day job wow
when was that holy [ __ ] that was 2014
when john oliver hired me
and before that i was i before that i
would say i'm a guy who does comedy okay
because i had a day job that makes sense
yeah you're not a professional yeah
that's that's how i saw it um and the
progression goes like this you start out
doing like the shittiest shows
imaginable i mean you go to open mics
and there's nobody there except the
other comics and then crazy people
because who would come to an open mic
sounds a little like politics and i'm
kidding
like when did you start getting paid
like 100 bucks or something like that in
my town the a club was the dc improv
feature of the dc improv is funny you
should say that exactly 100 bucks at
least it was back then it's probably
more now like big money you go there
it's like still a hundred it's very well
like supply and demand it could be 75
now i don't know
um but yeah that felt and that felt like
real money because you'll do a weekend
it'll be like seven shows 700 bucks
hell yes when i'm yeah that's like 27
that's great that feels real for sure
yeah yeah eventually i got to the point
where i could submit packets for stuff
right it's like
people were kind of aware of me
especially i moved to new york
in uh
late 2011 early 2012.
and
i got to submit packets for shows so i
put in a packet for like every terrible
show like a thousand shows that were
like very quickly canceled
and
like i would have been thrilled to have
gotten them so it's funny that the one
that i eventually got
was last week night with john oliver
that you know like stuck on the air and
was around so you get that gig and
you're like i mean that must feel also
like a made man you're like oh [ __ ] i'm
a tv writer yeah legit yeah hbo hit like
i said that's when i quit my day job
and um
when people said what do you do i say
comedian
instead of
i'm a speechwriter and i also do comedy
so when you were a tv writer for john
oliver you're you still just show up and
do clubs and sets all the long day is
that right yeah and and that's when
that's when it got easier for me like
that's when the comedy seller started
taking me you know that's when
caroline's gave a [ __ ] about me because
now i've got a halfway decent credit
which is important to them like they
need to they need to impress their
audience a little bit
it's like hey from the john oliver
writing room
i always hated sometimes an emcee who
didn't know anything would say you saw
him on last week tonight with john
oliver i'm like you did not see me
on last week tonight nobody's on that
show but john oliver
is your set actually political because
your blog goes into politics a great
deal and you do have an advanced degree
as we have established yeah the advanced
degree that all communities have
yes uh
it's funny
you're right
my work on john oliver was political my
blog is almost all political comedy my
stand-up was not political comedy yeah
that's funny
i'll tell you why though it's because
you lose the audience so quickly oh my
god you do political stuff because
you're doing it's like
when you say all right let's talk about
politics
exactly and on stage
yes yes if they weren't already saying
that and they often were but like
immediately you you lose half your
audience because they're like we don't i
just don't fall apart okay wait wait
let's review this argument um i'm i'm
thinking of other comedians who
do politics and i can't really think of
that many
it's a small number these days that's
like bill maher who you know there are
some they're people who are like
grandfathered in because you know they
were they've been around forever
or like certainly their audience
shows up knowing
they're going to get jon stewart i
suppose sure jon stewart but yes but jon
stewart's audience you know when he does
stand up now
they know
what they're getting what they're
getting yeah you've got to remember
like when you're being brought up as hey
here's yet another one like that's
basically your internet so what so what
did your comedy focus on i talked a lot
about working in an office it has to be
relatable stuff so it's like mike judge
office space type stuff that's fun a lot
of that yeah a lot of that because
people relate to that yeah sure and this
is why politics doesn't work it's like
people a lot of people don't relate to
it
you divide the audience once
when you say because half of them don't
care so you say i'm talking about
politics you lose half of them then
you're about to lose half of the half
that you have when you have any kind of
viewpoint
because if if i reveal that i'm liberal
then i'm going to lose the conservatives
just lost his podcast man yeah
you're dead to 20 25 percent of 20 right
now i'm just kidding i'm a hand or a
doctor that's why you had me no you know
he is very very heterodox and thoughtful
that's true so what's the process in
terms of uh subjects for
john oliver um because it's like there's
like a topic that you dig into obviously
very political smart i'm a fan i was a
fan of the show oh thanks um so well now
you lost your audience by
well yeah i guess so yeah you know
sorry guys if they're allergic to the
term liberals certainly they'll also be
alert legit to uh john oliver
specifically here like how many writers
were there in the room eight for most
the time i was there though by the time
i left it was 10.
um a lot it's more than that now i think
they're like 12 or 14 wow all four it's
like half an hour tv right yeah no the
the other shows hate us because they're
like so you do half an hour a week and
colbert does
you know
five hours a week but you know a lot of
that's like guests and musical guests
and ads and stuff but still like we yes
it is a um
it is a reduced schedule compared to
that but
we always find ways to fill the time
it's like it's a busy week i wasn't like
kicking off at four o'clock you know we
always
had [ __ ] to do
and it's a dense half hour it's a dance
there's a lot in that half hour but to
you you asked and i didn't answer uh
like what the process for coming up with
topics the topics get pitched by the
writers
and then also the researchers and the
you had researchers on top of the 10
writers i'm kidding
well then you start a show
if you're certain you can do it with a
skeleton
you're going to be about it you're
taking like a consultant's view of uh
comedy like you get you a lot of people
so the 10 writers and how many
researchers
uh started with
they kept growing it started with three
that was four that was five wow and then
four footage producers
wow can't forget about the footage
producers no but everybody pitches
everybody pitches so it could come from
anywhere so was there anything that you
were like hey my fingerprints all over
that stuff and i was really proud of and
you'd call someone to be like yo this
this this one was all me
well there are ones you're assigned to
so
every piece has usually two
lead writers
if it's a bigger one it might be four
but it's usually two
so yes you're assigned to those and at
the end everyone gets brought in so
everyone's involved with every piece in
a way
um but there are the ones you're
assigned to those are definitely yours
and then sometimes you do kind of pitch
one
and
then it gets on yeah there are some i
mean like a lot of the environmental
stuff
because i had worked at the epa for nine
years oh [ __ ] yeah they would bust you
out on all the environments yeah
yeah so and be like hey man you're mr
environment right you know pretty much
what's going on yeah you know so was
there like mr
foreign policy
different duties we did kind of get
lanes i i feel like i was also maybe mr
foreign policy because i did like i did
iran deal i did north korea
international trade was one i did
because again that's kind of my
wheelhouse
um but yeah people had different uh we
had a couple people who knew a lot about
like
news media because they had worked in
that previously so those pieces came
from them interesting uh my uh
office mate jill twist did a lot of the
stuff on like women's rights and things
like that
[Music]
life can be overwhelming we all know
this
often we burn out without even realizing
it so
that can end up being lack of motivation
or irritability or fatigue or
just shortness things like that and i
want to talk to you guys about better
help because it is a type of online
therapy that wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself and helps you just
kind of work through your thoughts
personally i use better help use it a
lot during covid
but just to i called it my steam valve
just to blow off some steam just to
collect my thoughts talk about things i
don't necessarily want
to talk about publicly
with someone online to carely privately
personally so better help if you don't
know is a customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera even
if you don't want to it's private secure
it's convenient easy to schedule it's
awesome it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours so really really easy
to start so listen our listeners of
forward podcast are going to get 10 off
their first month that's betterhelp.com
yang so check it out that's
betterhelp.com
yang take care of your head guys check
it out right now betterhelp.com
[Music]
so there's this this notion of
uh hollywood liberal elites like new
york cultural elites like were the um
the political
leanings of
the the writers like relatively uniform
heterodox like all over the place uh uh
when i you know so the original writing
staff the original eight i would say we
were kind of like eight obama-era
liberals
you're just not going to get many
conservatives
in this field
it's like think about who you're drawing
from right it's like okay first they're
almost all comedy writers are highly
educated you know
they almost certainly went to college i
i honestly i'm not sure i know a comedy
writer i know tons of stand-ups but
comedy writer who didn't go to college i
don't think i know single one
interesting and almost always like a
fancy pants college sorry right um and
then they live in a city
they're almost certainly young
they probably
these days i came up through stand up
that's a little odd these days more
commonly these days they would have come
from improv the improv if you ever hang
around you know we're in new york second
city in new york like that's a really
far left kind of click
um so like these are the demographics
you're drawing from there are just not a
lot of conservatives in that pool
so oh makes perfect sense so you'd uh so
uh
your
writings are endlessly entertaining so i
urge everyone to check it out at i might
be wrong
uh
and i i would see you as well i mean you
you say in your blog that you know like
you were
like at a certain point and then there
was this notion that the sides ran off
to like you know ran off to the extreme
yeah like you might have drifted a
particular direction
but there was one recent blog post that
i thought was really funny which was um
like you
characterize the the left not as like
left and extreme
left it's like there's like the left and
people who believe in various policies
like let's say climate change which you
know in my mind like people i think
people know that
like i think that's a
near existential threat that's a big
threat yeah
it's a big thing um but then you
characterize folks on the the extreme
left as sort of like they're not extreme
left anymore they're something else yeah
yeah well yeah that that's uh
that is how i feel i do feel that um
we don't have a name for this you know
what no
progress it was super progressive yeah
so you said that there were a few
different like wesley yang called them
what
the the successor ideology and then i
say religious left
because i'm from
a part of the south that's pretty
religious oh what what part of south
africa norfolk area in my town in great
bridge virginia it's pretty it's a
pretty conservative area or at least
certainly was
you know a ton of the people that i'm
aligned with in the ford party like are
are like exposed to religious
communities and they're they're just
like anyway well that sounds like me as
well it was
my my family oddly was like the one
family that was like not all that
religious but
very religious area that really made an
impression on me and that's why i often
refer to what's happening now as the
religious left because they very much
remind me of those people i knew when i
was younger that they have
they have you know these beliefs that
they adhere to
you know in my mind past the point of
all logic and that's what i was getting
at
uh in the piece you're referring to it's
called the great dominant on my sub
stack i might be wrong
and
i because i i still consider myself a
liberal and i consider myself on the
left and the the stuff that um
people want
is i often find it not very progressive
i find it you know not very
helpful to the poor
not very not very multicultural a lot of
the time
it's it's it seems just completely
foreign to me so yeah that's why i
described it as kind of an invading
force i'm going to tell you a story it's
you know a relatively true story um so i
i decided to run for president i
remember that yeah um uh on universal
basic income which is give everyone a
thousand bucks a month
and i thought i'd be left of bernie
because it's like well even bernie
stopped short of just being like let's
give everyone money by the way i was
like you know after bernie the whole
freaking campaign to be like hey burn in
like like get on board uh and then
bernie came out for a federal jobs
guarantee and i was like oh it's like
not really the
[Laughter]
um
but the left
did not respond positively to universal
basic income uh initially
like and i was attacked as i don't know
like anti-uh
anti-welfare
like a libertarian trojan horse right
like a bunch of things and i was like
bewildered by it and i was like guys you
do realize i'm like trying to like
give everyone a thousand bucks a month i
mean last i checked that would be quite
good for people who don't have a
thousand bucks i mean like it seems like
a win seems like a left-wing policy
seems relatively left aligned yeah and
and i mean it was because you didn't
wear the socialist label do you think
that's that's why they didn't go for
that well well that this is a part of it
it's like that i had an identity and
more what i've included jeff is that
it's more like i had an attitude and an
energy that didn't line up with like
that general school of thought yeah um
because like i'm a positive can do guy
and like i talk about the evolution of
capitalism um
and the case i was making for universal
basic income which i totally believe
um was that look this is like uh
um this is good for market economies
that people have money to spend it's
like good for small businesses like you
know like you you this is just a better
functioning
system
um and
uh and so i was trying to make this
argument to people
at every point in the
um you know like sort of political uh
scale or leaning um and i you know i did
say it's like look like they were
libertarian thinkers who like liked
versions of this and uh you know it's
like nixon
kim is close to passing a version of
this and then like i figured the left
frankly would take care of itself
um
well i was wrong on that maybe because
then that thing like it was being like
attacked in various ways it was only
after
months and months passed where
eventually
uh a bunch of folks in the left started
using universal basic income at
something they were calling for yeah
it's bizarre the one that kills me these
days is uh universal student loan
forgiveness which
some people are calling for
i think some student loan forgiveness
makes sense
i had actually had a piece of the new
york times about how i think
the thing the thing i hope people know
about universal forgiveness is that it's
regressive if you're if you're forgiving
literally every penny to everybody so so
35
of americans have college degrees
so uh if you were to try and find the
bottom 50 percent of the population
i'm going to say
majority of them probably do not have
tax degrees well i actually i know this
number because i just wrote about it 87
of americans don't have any student debt
so i feel like right away when you're
talking about student debt you're
talking about something that basically
means nothing to 87 percent of the
country i mean sure you know it's like
yeah maybe you don't but your child does
but yeah right
but um
it so
and again i've written about this
also on my blog it just you and let me
qualify again universal forgiveness i'm
for some forgiveness but universal
forgiveness would be regressive so i
feel like i'm to the left and i'm
arguing with people who think they are
to my left but i think they're wrong i
think they're to my right
and it's just bizarre to have these
conversations where like
i mean you know of course when i did the
new york times piece you know twitter
called me like a
you know wall street bro i'm like you
you so don't [ __ ] know who you're
talking about or for the epa we're
trying to heal the earth i would say the
peace corps the epa it's not it's like
you know do your research but um and i
really strongly feel like
no i'm to the left on this you idiot you
know did you see the uh ryan grim piece
uh and the intercept uh came out this
weekend no um i will summarize it for
you it's called the elephant and the
zoom and it's a it's like why dc
progressive
um
organizations have devolved into
internal oh wait yes i did see that yes
i did see that yeah yes yeah that was
that was quite good so so there's
something happening man where
people are now waking up to the fact
it's like uh wait a minute
like
this this stuff isn't actually
what it purports to be it's not good for
organizations it's not good for
individuals
um have you read uh woke racism by john
mcwhorter i'm like quizzing you on oh i
love john mcgordr i've not read that
book but i i certainly know i've cause i
heard him on a thousand podcasts yeah
yeah the argument that he makes in it
yeah yeah so so that was one of the best
summaries i mean when you call the
religious left i mean he calls it
essentially the same yeah yeah no i'm
very much in tune with him on that yeah
yeah so so um but that there's been this
um
awakening to the fact that these and by
the way so i ran a nonprofit um and when
you talk about the the folks who join
comedy writers rooms is like a
particular background when you look at
folks who join i'm get i'm very
confident like dc area or new york area
nonprofits like you know did they go to
college check do they tend to go to
college east coast check like
and then and it's like did if you join a
non-profit are you driven by certain
um uh
goals and ideas which tend to make you
line up with
um like uh like a certain orientation
totally yeah um and so by the way
there's also true media which is like
another yeah
another problem from what i know of
media yeah yeah so so that
that also the democratic party let me
add oh yeah same the same type of thing
yeah oh yeah it's true political
activism then someone came out and said
i mean like one of the
you know like the the
um
examples of this is like the entire
latinx thing i mean like you know it's
like literally two percent of people
like it and sixty percent hate it you're
like
you're like oh this is a winner it's
like winner four
yeah you know winning elections that's
clearly not two percent you know for
your sense of you know righteousness
yeah it's a winner for that yeah right
like you know it's gonna you're gonna
righteousness all the way to
authoritarianism in a hot minute
it's like
the um
the sense but you know so i see more and
more
stuff where people are like okay and but
uh the the story i was trying to get to
was that um people i know who ran
non-profits like lived in fear of their
own staff
because the the staff was going to
to uh you know pillory them for
some lapse of uh you know like beliefs
yeah look at the washington post last
week they're worried of that right
the felicia somnes
um and watching that unfold publicly was
you know painful for all so i sense that
you were kind of entertained by it
i was very entertained by it i i wrote a
piece about how entertained by it i was
yeah it was hilar i mean i got no skin
in that game it was just hilarious to
watch somebody burn their organization
to the ground on twitter for a week and
they can't [ __ ] do anything about it
and the organization's the washington
post
and they finally got around to find her
firing her dude it had to be a legal
thing i don't know if you saw after
that like i was reflecting on it and
like i didn't wait in on
that and on twitter because like yeah
it's like not my thing and like i try
very very hard not to
not to um
like frankly get bogged down in like the
the kind of media spots and twitter back
and forth like i think that's a path to
unproductivity and and um insanity
insanity yeah um but i did reflect for a
moment on what i thought the real
problem was the fix and so i said like
hey you know you should just get all
journalists off twitter it'd be a win
for the journalists and a win for
uh the public
[Laughter]
and then i proceeded to be like look
like this stuff's just like you know
like putting our journalists in like
this weird like like
um
bubble and like you know they seek
affirmation a particular way and it's
like making them more ideological and
like probably makes them unhappy and
like
there's a bunch of things and it was
clearly like a thought experiment on my
part but it's driven by the washington
post thing yeah because like watching
adults
trash each other and their organization
uh like publicly was just like you know
i mean this is like it's not good and
it's the washington post
which has to be credible you have to be
a credible serious organization
populated by adults or else your product
is not one anyone's going to want to buy
and they did not look like that
[Music]
so
so i i put out a twitter poll yesterday
i'm like just talking about my own
tweets so sorry everyone but uh but but
it was like who do you trust the most
category one politicians category two
comedians including you my friend ah
paul can you win because of me category
number three people think comedian they
think jeff maurer
yeah
um
and then category number three
journalists what do you think the
percentages are
uh how about comedians 50
no no probably comedians higher than
that
because the again the other two are
journalists and politicians i'm going to
say comedians 70
journalists
20 politicians 10.
83 ah [ __ ]
15
two
two
boy
it was like
it was so extreme it was ridiculous yeah
uh and so one of the things i've been
struggling with a little bit in my own
life jeff is that that like there are
times where i have thoughts that are
somewhat inappropriate i find them to be
funny
occasionally i'll tweet something and
then you know sometimes i get a hot
water and i'm like oh come on like come
on you know i'm just [ __ ] around
so so one of the things i'm i'm um
thinking about is
uh trying to
be be
frankly like just like a humorous figure
more
deliberately because like now it's like
i've been like a political uh figure
um
for not that long really i mean like
maybe four years are you saying you have
a packet you want me to hand on to john
oliver is that where this is
[Laughter]
uh well so but i was imagining what
people need and your blog is an approach
to this where you're like look i'm gonna
deliver to you it's gonna be funny and
this blog is quite funny everyone i
might be wrong it's funny um but there
but there are serious ideas in there
um and so
you think that in order to get people to
consider politics you need what you
called like some sugar yeah the the
sugar that helps the medicine go down
yeah yeah it's like and so this is one
of those last week tonight is i mean in
america yeah right and it's one reason
why again 83 percent jews comedians as
the people they trust and then
journalists like you know 15 and the
rest so because there's a sense that
comedians are telling us the truth
um journalists are presenting something
but we can sense that it's skewing in
particular directions and by the way
this is one thing that the parties are
sharply divided on it's one reason why
you know like i'm i'm doing what i'm
doing so
uh 69 of self-described um liberals
democrats et cetera have high trust in
media
um
independence it's 39 percent okay and
then independent republicans is 15
okay so republicans are like [ __ ] this
liberals like you know lying to us
[ __ ] yeah you know now obviously
there are some elements of that that are
like really like frankly you know dark
and like they they you know become prone
to misinformation conspiracy theories
um but like the the democrats are kind
of like the last of like the people that
trust
in a particular way but more and more
the populations like we question we we
don't trust
um and then you you have both
politicians and journalists represent
this establishment that people are
losing faith in
um and then comedians are given license
to poke fun
at the establishment right um and we we
say we laugh but we're also like yeah
that that that [ __ ] is right part of
what you just said that uh worried me a
little is that people think comedians
are telling them the truth
which
certainly sometimes they are you lied to
us jeff no not me no no no no one time
on that stage in d.c
that story wasn't he did not just fly in
from cleveland and his arms are not
tired
no i uh sometimes they're telling the
truth but it's it's like anything else
people should remember you know comedy
like it's still media like they're still
trying to get eyeballs so yeah sometimes
it's very truthful but i wouldn't assume
all the time i mean christ's sake be
discerning
fact check those comedians no seriously
yes fact check the comedians but um
yeah i don't know it's institutional
trust is such a weird thing for me
because i've been such an institutional
guy for so long i was at epa for nine
years so like during covid every time
the cdc
or
the fda
would do something to undermine their
credibility i would just lose my mind
i'd be apoplectic because it's like that
that is your
most valuable asset that is the thing
you cannot do
is lose people's trust and i think you
know the thing you know for example
in the early days when they said uh oh
you know
and the masks don't do much and then
later they admitted well we were kind of
saying that because we were worried that
there would be a run on masks and i
understand why they
made that decision and yet i think tell
the [ __ ] tell us the truth because
you undermined your credibility so badly
and again i understand like how that
thought process happened but your
credibility is your most valuable asset
so that type of decision is one that me
as a long-time institutional guy is like
no
no you really blew that me as a longtime
fan of the washington post
thinks like you have got to get your
credibility back you've got to stop
publicly
clowning yourself
i think slowly people are getting that
i think so so the institutional trust
and as someone who's looked at the
numbers and you probably have looked at
them too gallup etc uh they're all
um they're not good yeah yeah they're
all quite low uh
you know uh
think public approval of congress and
trust in congress is down to like what
nineteen percent something really really
low yeah uh presidency is underwater
below fifty percent um in the most
trusted institutions in american life
guess
oh god uh hot dog carts and strip clubs
u.s military
okay and uh town libraries law
enforcement's still pretty high
libraries yeah people trust librarians
okay
uh i'm not sure what to do with that um
but you look at other schools down
hospitals down
or librarians and trust me oh sorry
apparently we should give them more
power i mean that's one of my i guess
ideas you know
i'm sorry go ahead so trust is down
except for in the libraries
military too which by the way is
probably like uh you know foreshadowing
for where the country is going to wind
up
um oh my god
i mean you know probably
um so
uh i mean ray dalio when i you know like
biggest hedge fund uh founder in the
world uh you know runs 200 billion
dollars put the odds of a civil war
in the u.s for the next 10 years at 30
percent in his book and then in
conversation take that is he taking bets
and then in conversation he was like
it's higher than 30 now he's like i
wrote that 18 months ago so it's higher
now um
so that you're so when i talk it's like
oh you know these people trust the
military like you know maybe at some
point military's going to step in and
do some things seems like i hear people
talk about this boy i would take that
bet that seems incredibly unlikely to me
um i mean certainly hope you're right
you know like uh so i'm on the but i'm
on like the hey we should really be
trying to refresh and modernize and
invigorate um some of these
institutional arrangements um because
the two-party system in particular it
has us at each other's throats and when
you talk about like these folks on what
you call the religious left it's like
the problem is they're whip-sawing major
institutions that then represent you
know like the democratic party to like
other people and then it's very easy to
just point at them and be like look guys
you they want these people in charge and
then they're are folks in that kind of
party's like no that's not me yes um you
know and then the same thing happens in
reverse which is like if you look at the
you know looniest republicans i mean
it's very very dark and so then
democrats like you want them in charge i
mean like the democratic party should be
at least two separate parties by now
uh then the republican party should be
two separate parties by now yeah and
you'd have like a fifth party in the
middle and this would be sane you'd have
if you were europe that's probably what
it would be
yeah or you know but so right now we're
careening towards uh you know something
of a disaster um so one of the things
that that is happening too is that the
the democratic party doesn't have much
of the sugar you're describing in terms
of humor it's like it's a real humorous
yeah yeah we are not seen as a super
super funny right now we're not the good
time party right now no no problem very
much not i mean if there's an operative
emotion coming out of the democratic
party right now it's fear
uh and and then and you can't use fear
to motivate people at infinitum like at
some point people just check out you
know what i mean
[Music]
i think one thing that's disappointing
is that
the people that were all thinking of you
know the really humorous people on
twitter where as you said like sometimes
you want to say something you think oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna i'm gonna hear from
somebody about that it's like i don't
even i don't even know how that's
offensive but somebody will figure out
some way that's offensive and find some
way and i just don't want to deal with
that i still feel like i feel like one
thing twitter does is bring you in touch
with that person whereas before they
were out there you just didn't know they
were out there you didn't hear from them
i'm going to say this much much worse
man like that person exists because of
twitter
that person if twitter doesn't exist
that person is not sitting there being
like american
because there's no actual uh you know
um positive reinforcement for them yeah
it's like like if someone said something
that they didn't like and there was no
twitter then they can't get to that
person
and then they're just living their life
being like whatever i think you're
probably right about that uh certainly
twitter like twitter has a culture
twitter has just there's just something
about the like format of twitter that
lends itself to dunks it's like all
about the dunks people just sitting
around waiting for somebody to dunk on
and
so yeah i think you're right that
it's it's more arabic it's more hostile
than maybe people used to be nonetheless
i still think the number of people who
are actually like that
is still relatively small they're just
really loud oh yeah so there are numbers
for this man numbers for everything um
[Laughter]
i forgot how data driven your world is
yeah yeah that so um there are
approximately
15 percent of people who fall into to
what you'd consider like a far left
progressive camp and then there's like a
subset of them that are in
what what you'd considered this uh you
know religious
group but they're very very loud on
twitter
um so
so i i'm
looking at ways i've written three books
one of which was before i was you know
like
anybody and so it sold a few copies and
i was like fine with that
actually i'll tell you a story that is
pretty funny so
write a book
um you know sell some copies and then i
go to my agent and you know i'm like one
of his like you know smallest like you
know um
authors and i'm like hey i'm i'm writing
a book uh and i'm gonna run for
president on it um you know about
automation so
yeah so make that work and so he's like
okay
so uh we write this proposal and it's
like hey andrew yang is going to run for
president universal basic income the
books about automation
and then the publishers all are like you
know frankly just being like
like i've seen some proposals that like
make claims before but like no one takes
the entire like run for president
like etcetera thing seriously yeah and
so then my agent later when like i i
um
i'm on the debate stage with like
elizabeth warren and they asked like
what gift you want to give and i'm like
i'd give elizabeth warren a copy of my
book um and then i come off stage and
then my my team's like hey by the way
you're like books like trending and like
now yeah everyone's like buying it and
so then my agent calls me and is like
like your book proposal
like is like the was the most far out
thing that i've ever seen come true in
like my years as an agent because
we were like you're gonna do this thing
so um so that book is now sold like 175
180 000 copies which is a lot for a book
um but still isn't reaching people in
certain ways so i'm like looking for
different ways to try and frame
um some of these messages and i'm
becoming increasingly convinced that
humor is a path oh yeah um so that so
it's one of the things i'm i'm now
especially with this now like we trust
comedians more
like and and and the rest of it i'm
looking at it and the humorlessness
that's coming out of our politics right
now yeah the humorless is a real bad
look and it's a real big problem
and i i hope
people are figuring out that it's a big
problem and
trump was funny trump was funny wow you
said it yeah trump was funny and i don't
i don't mean the jokes about trump which
i spent many years writing to the point
that i wanted to you know throw myself
off a bridge i don't mean those are
funny i mean trump himself he's he's a
performer he's a performer yes and it's
like it's all very dark it's all real
bad stuff but like he's entertaining and
you would see him at those rallies that
were you know when he was really getting
momentum in like late 2015 and 2016 it's
like he's basically doing stand-up yes
and we always said in the last week
tonight writer's room he's doing this
because i was not the only stand up
there he's doing this like a stand-up
and that he is going out and he's seeing
what lines hit and then if they hit it's
like drain the swamp who saw drain the
swamp coming and what the [ __ ] was he
talking about nobody ever knew including
him but like drain the swamp hit so then
you just got during the swamp all the
time by the way drain the swamp is a
very powerful
idea because no offense to you know your
former town and whatnot but you know i
mean the swamp my current i currently
live in dc oh really yeah your current
town then the swamps pretty swampy man
yeah sometimes but yes but is donald
trump
the person
of course not it's the opposite but by
the way i had the same process because
like i was marching around the country
in 2018 we did the humanity first tour
and like you know very small thank you
everyone who showed up there weren't
many of you so if you were there you
know
um and and so for me it was uh opposite
of of trump's an asian guy who likes
math um became an applause line and then
from that math became
make america think harder and then
became like this emily because the man
had behind me on the
the shelf and so we sold three million
dollars worth of math hats and uh you
know like that did you really yeah yeah
okay so it was so yours it was mostly a
merch operation no no
we raised 40 million dollars so i mean
you know three million only like
whatever like eight eight percent of
that so um you got money from sam b
right we got money sam do you remember
that
sam beckmann oh this is funny oh this is
funny samantha b you've got samantha b
thank you samantha bee yeah yeah we won
the competition very grateful
it was awesome but you know when we
raised 40 million dollars from like
something like 425 000 uh americans in
increments like the average like the
median donation was very low it was like
you know like 27 30 bucks something like
that so um there was a quarter that i
raised half of what bernie raised and i
was running around yelling we're half a
bernie we're half of bernie but it's
like very very
wholesome grassroots
uh funded campaign and then the merch
became a part of that but our process
was the same as trump's where we were
going to live crowds and so this is one
of the problems is that you have most uh
politicians where they have a stump
i've seen them give their [ __ ] stump
a million times like like one of the
jokes i have in my book is like you just
have us all give each other stumps
because we've all seen it [ __ ] so
many times
and then i i'd
joke it's like i would actually pay to
see
like uh you know bernie stand up there
and do the yang which is like hey the
robots are coming we're doing give
everyone a thousand bucks you know it'd
be pretty funny
um
but trump was a performer trump was
humorous he had a particular energy and
he captured harness this
anti-institutional energy that on the
republican side is much much stronger um
so they overran the traditional
republican candidates he's going to do
it again in 24 if he runs in my opinion
which i think he will so i think he
winds up the republican nominee i'm
going to disagree with you there but but
i think he's going to run i don't think
he's going to win oh wow yeah that's my
hot take i think he's going to run and
lose to who
desantis
okay
if desantis runs
then it's a death match it's competitive
and uh like it's anyone's game do you
think desantis is not gonna run i don't
think desantis runs really no okay
i think he's i think he's gonna run and
i think but we've been talking about
this in terms of entertainment right
talking about trump and like ah man the
trump show in 2015 people very into the
trump show yeah i think people are tired
of that show
yeah i think that's one of the big
factors that in in
ukraine ukraine's not going to because
all the russia stuff's gonna come back
up and it looks very salient right now
and well so
i think people are tired of that show oh
well you need
a foil you need an opponent if desantis
runs i think that it's anyone's game and
i might even favor desantis i do not
think desantis runs because one heard he
was telling donors x months ago it's
been a little while if trump runs he
doesn't run but two
is that if you're
uh
self-interested in your stance it's like
let me do the math i run against trump
we have a death match split the base
massive ranker you know some of these
people are frankly like not entirely
balanced and so there there'd be some
folks that are like kind of you know
like hardcore on one side or another
um maybe i come out on top but like you
know i come out very very scarred and
bruised and with like tons of
uh like people that are like against me
still because trump will have like a
strong hold on on x or i like wait the
cycle i'm the heir apparent i'm still in
my late 40s uh if trump wins then like
you know maybe i end up like vice
president then i just glide into the uh
white house maybe you know it's like uh
like i'm there's no reason to think my
popularity's gonna disappear between now
and then it's just if you're him
it makes more sense just to cool cool it
if trump runs the cycle which i think he
does
maybe i mean you know we'll definitely
find out if ron desantis is not running
for president he's doing a great
impression of a guy who is
oh i find his behavior really hard to
explain
well so it's not just him there are half
a dozen people who are running around
like acting as if they're going to run
for president because you kind of have
to well you know you've done it so i
suppose you yeah i do can read the tea
leaves right um but it's it's
politically advantageous for you to do
so because it's like you're in this
period where people be like oh let me
check you out like you might run for
president you build relationships with
donors so like even if your plan is to
run
um you know in in in 28
if trump runs number one trump could
have a heart attack tomorrow so then
you're on um
and then you know you're just uh paving
your your way um because there are
massive contingencies so you will
operate to your team it's like let's
freaking act like we're doing this thing
but when push comes to shove if trump
runs i think he sits it out that's
interesting well i'm
for a million reasons i'm just glad i'm
not in republican politics i'm glad i
don't have to figure that out
or deal with that guy and i'm also not a
late night comedy writer anymore so i
don't have to deal with trump
in any way shape or form which is a
blessing
[Music]
so is trump's act aging yes
um
but but you need a better act
and the the problem is that uh if you
have
any number of mainstream republicans
um who run against trump that's not the
act that anyone wants like people don't
want
chris christie or mike pence standing
there looking boring being like you know
americans
when marco rubio tried to get trumpy at
the very end when when his campaign was
in the death throes
it was just not a good look for him it
didn't work yeah you can't when he when
he was like making fun of his hands and
stuff and you remember that yeah dude
right the very end of his campaign yeah
yeah it's like you can't just flip a
switch and suddenly be trump so so so
this is the the fundamental problem
we're facing so you have trump as an act
and like you know agree it's getting
tired but there is no other act unless
it's hard to come by yeah it's a sweep
and the the democratic party is like
kind of like the fearful last of the
institutionalists um and then if someone
comes in with it so when mcconaughey um
you know did his white house
event i was like matthew mcconaughey has
presidential qualities um sure and he's
an actor he's got charisma and this is
the issue is that in my opinion
um we need
a world-class performer
or an act
that's benign and positive that can
actually
count about so the problem is if you
have like trump in this you know messed
up act and then you have like the these
like institutionalists like the
institutionalists are going to lose
um yeah and so you you need like another
version
that has some kind of
energy
uh appeal like it isn't hitting the same
um sort of
uh tutting tones
the cutting is not a good one yeah um
yeah it's hard to you need the whole
package and that's hard to come by i
mean
ronald reagan was an actor
and he hasn't he's a comedian you know
he's a comedian that's right so i want
to ask you one of the things that that i
ask some of my comedian friends and we
can close out on this um
uh
which of your comedian buddies do you
think should run for president
oh cause they'd be good at it i'm just
gonna while he's thinking i'm gonna
preface this by being like look having
done this
a comedian an actor or a professional
wrestler would be
extraordinarily part of the rock with
the rock have a lot of success if you
ran the rock would be great mcconaughey
would be great mark cuban would be great
i do feel the need to ask the questions
like does the rock actually know
anything about you know
foreign policy economics seems like a
nice guy the rock can have a world-class
team around him and and all would be
coming oh that's what they said about
trump that's what they said about trump
oh but trump's uh
you know i like i i think the rock is
plenty smart enough to be able to lead
this in particular like intelligence and
then there's knowledge and like i want
my president to have knowledge and
additions too in addition to
intelligence that's a high bar you're
setting up yeah
it is you know why because it's the
goddamn president
dude where where where to point now man
where we're going to get two out of
three we gotta get two other things i
mean joking my act around the time
trump ran that's like you know people
say he's like me you're not supposed to
want a president like you
the president is supposed to be a
thousand times better than you because
the goddamn president so again comedian
actor
uh professional wrestler
um like uh like i think that that uh
having done this
there they'd have a lot of success and
and one of the issues one of the reasons
why in my opinion where we're like being
set up to fail
is that if you have someone who has this
sort of energy like you know uh
uh you know one person that i'm gonna
have on the podcast shortly like uh
jesse ventura who became uh governor of
minnesota as an independent had that
version of this energy so the problem is
that democrats look at this person and
be like haha it's a joke these people
don't have and again it's because
they're like the last of the
institutional holdouts
um and so like the people in the media
will like you know like dismiss the
mcconaughey's the world or like whatever
the hell it is
um
the so um but having you know again been
through
um
this arc
like i can see why these people would
excel
and then the question is whether the
media actually piles in behind them um
so obama like when you look at it like
obama was an excellent performer now he
was an intellect he yeah he was one of
the few who was the whole package yeah
he he had the brains he had the
knowledge
and he was charismatic
yeah i mean he had a great bio
he was the whole package yeah yeah and
he doesn't come along every day so so
one of one of the things i'm going to
suggest to everyone is like look at this
point our politicians have become
performers
we should just acknowledge that and just
find like some [ __ ] awesome
performers
so with that as my my opportunity for
you to uh reflect who's who's it going
to be i'm going to give an answer your
number one
it's going to be it's going to be it's
going to be a slight cheat but i don't
think that makes it any less interesting
al franken
al franken
not a bad choice let's reopen that case
because we know more about what happened
and um i think we should reopen that
case we should definitely reopen that
case um generally you know i know a half
dozen people who were
uh cancelled lost their jobs
like you know lost their livelihood over
stuff that now we're like what
yeah
and he's and he's one of them i was on
that list yeah um and he and he he he's
a knowledgeable guy he's a knowledge you
know
no i've never met him never met him but
of course i like him very much because
he first of all out he's funny he's
funny he's smart he's funny he's funny
so i i was on his podcast so i have that
contact with him um it's funny it's like
you know like podcast bros
um but that's a fine response i'll take
it well thanks the the other uh popular
figures that um
to that when i pose it jon stewart sure
sure we're gonna hear that for decades
and then another one too that has come
up that uh you know i've i've been
um you know late night uh uh with him
and i'm i'm like 100 certain that this
will never happen
uh dave chappelle
sure yeah so dave's like
[Laughter]
um he's got other priorities
dave's like you know if you win you have
to do it you know you have to it's a
grind
and uh you really gotta want it to sign
up for that specific gig i agree that
you know yeah you need somebody with
charisma
who
you know you didn't do that badly but
you need somebody who who
is has the charisma but i i got to go
back to the chops so i'm not i i'm not
into the idea of you know finding
finding an actor and then just be like
well we'll just coach them up we'll give
them you know econ 101 and then that'll
uh
give them the knowledge they need to you
know for example like right now we have
a very tricky problem involving
inflation but here's the thing i'm gonna
say man is we had like establishment
people in there and it didn't prevent it
from happening you know what i mean it's
like like you you have this kind of
like the this thing where
you know it's like the jfk establishment
smartest people in the room et cetera et
cetera it's like you have people you
know like our establishment at this
point has become great at apologizing
after the fact and then you know like to
taking in like the institutional
mistrust that's built up i feel like we
had the experiment with
the anti-institutionalists
the people who are kind of making the
argument that you're making right now
with like oh they don't [ __ ] know
anything with trump and that's what
trump was
and he [ __ ] the bed on so many things i
mean it looks like we're finally getting
reduced terrorists there's no like trump
trump didn't know what he's doing with
the tariff there's no trump defense here
yeah but but the the thing that so
here's what's happening is that you have
these institutions that are you know
fumbling failing sometimes they're great
sometimes they're like really not great
but even when they're not great it's not
like anyone really raise their hand is
like hey guys our bad like you know like
there's like zero
like uh
accountability accountability or
acknowledgement even or
any kind of revamping it's just like you
know especially in this day and age
because we're so polarized that they can
just be like hey you know like to our
people it's like we good they bet um and
then you have this like force outside
being like getting bigger and bigger
being like oh like you know where we we
don't like what's happening and so if
you just play the institutionalist game
like this force just keeps going up this
keeps going down and then you lose
cataclysmically um the the only way out
is to try and actually
come clean and being like look some of
these institutions you know i've gotten
a bad rap some of them genuinely not
that good um but we need to revamp them
meaningfully we need to revamp our
political system so we have five parties
instead of two we have to like i and the
problem is that the existing systems
will never do more than what we're
describing right now which is that they
will be here being like no we didn't
really scrub so bad it's not so bad
and then like more and more i mean like
you talk about inflation like the
average american right now is just like
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
um you know my gas is five bucks plus
and i did it on like that you know and
and like that they're not gonna be able
to see past this
um that we can like
you think matthew mcconaughey is the guy
to fix all this i think that we need
someone who's going to
come in with a broom and
clean up shop he'd be able to
communicate he's like a nice guy he's a
good actor he'd be able to to
communicate the american people in a
different way he'd be able to approach
institutional dysfunction in a different
way
you could have people that might
genuinely make some changes like in a in
a in like a real way um like we're going
to need a realignment of some kind like
that to get out of this mess because
like the holding action that's losing is
just going to keep losing more ground
incrementally and and the audience
that's going to respond to it is going
to shrink and shrink it's like the
average person out there is just like
checking out more and more
and you know and like and that like that
the only way out is to get them to check
back in to something positive something
new and then you need like someone who
can get to them in a different way
because you you have like the
traditional media and that audience is
going to shrink and shrink and like you
know and the trust go down and down you
have people like you who like i i think
are awesome who are like independent
journalists who
uh you know not that you consider
yourself journalists no not a journalist
yeah yeah you know
that's why he's in the 83 percent high
trust comedian zone that's not in the
50s
but they're like independent voices yeah
uh
and like what we need is there are a lot
of independent voices right now that i
think are very very positive um and uh
and we we need the independent um
figures voices
to actually have a shot
at any kind of a and by the way the
people who are like super pissed off and
coming up on this side they might see
like a matthew mcconaughey figure and be
like okay
like i and there are millions of
americans in this category i signed on
to trump because i wanted to stick a
thumb in the eye of the establishment
that's it like you know uh and matthew
mcconaughey
also like fulfills my desire to stick a
thumb in the eye of the establishment
sure but he's just not a raging lunatic
or like you know like an [ __ ] i think
i think we're talking about trust here
aren't we we're talking about trust
people want a candidate they feel they
can trust
if somebody feels like a creature of an
institution
coming out of some some
institutional body that maybe you don't
trust you don't think very highly of or
you think they represent that
institution in some way they're going to
have trouble getting your trust like i
understand that
and even if they're a good person if
they get wrapped within this cocoon yeah
of of like uh you know political
consultants and media
they start talking like a robot and then
they go out there and they just start
like doing the same
yeah it could be but
we're talking about trust and including
institutional trust and of course any
institution is only as trustworthy as
the people who are in it
i agree
i agree that
first i agree that
people
in the institutions
are not always doing a great job of
earning people's trust and that's a
goddamn shame and that is something i
write about all the time on my blog and
i've said it on this podcast people in
the institutions need to realize their
credibility is their main asset and they
need to protect that with their lives
yeah
librarians
i i still feel their skill set might be
somewhat limited but yes sure a
librarian is fine they i
i simply don't want to denigrate the
idea of expertise i think expertise is
still important i think knowledge is
still important i love expertise and
knowledge okay well then we're on the
same page there so please do check out
jeff's blog i might be wrong hey andrew
yang agrees i also might be wrong we all
might be wrong
and uh thank you jeff for for being here
and uh hopefully giving people a little
bit of
an insight into how
media is made and how the heck someone
becomes a professional comedian yeah go
work for the epa for nine years it works
every time every time look at that it's
an army of comics coming out of that
office thanks jeff thanks for having me
[Music]
you